oil moves the world around and creates
powerful countries oil is such a vital
commodity that it provoked Wars
throughout the 20th century the few
countries that produce it try to keep
control of it to ensure its riches stay
at home those who do not have it strive
to get it in the 1930s Saudi Arabia was
one of the poorest countries in the
world but the discovery of oil
transformed it and Saudi Arabia has
amassed 515 point six billion dollars in
sovereign wealth funds it has become the
linchpin of a powerful cartel that
sometimes rations oil to push up prices
the United States is now the biggest
producer of oil and gas going to its
shale revolution it is tapped abundant
reserves through fracking
a technology that uses high-pressure
water and sand to fracture rock deep
below the ground to extract hydrocarbons
this shale revolution has helped the
United States become less dependent on
oil imported from Saudi Arabia Venezuela
Iraq and other OPEC countries more oil
and gas on global markets has also
benefited the world's energy consumers
by pushing down costs oil still remains
the primary fuel supplying almost 1/3 of
the world's energy but its heyday may
soon be over
despite growing demand while 2014 the
world's global energy use is set to
increase by 30 percent that energy must
be much cleaner if the world wants to
prevent catastrophic global warming in
the past
coal and gas were less expensive than
renewable technology
but their costs have come down
dramatically there is now a race among
some nations to create more efficient
renewable technologies to reduce
pollution and be more energy
self-sufficient
China is the world's largest consumer of
coal and the second largest of oil but
it also now leads the world in clean
energy one third of the world's new wind
power and solar panels is installed in
China and it sells more electric cars
than any other country the quest for
energy self-sufficiency is a big
motivation than many countries China is
moving fast an America under President
Donald Trump is securing its energy
independence with oil and gas but unlike
oil and gas renewables will not increase
global warming the long term transition
to clean energy will throw up new global
challenges it will create tensions in
unstable parts of the Middle East as oil
revenue starts to dry up another
challenge is that wind and Sun are
intermittent renewables may require vast
shared electricity grids spanning
borders to make them more efficient to
stop global warming the world needs a
huge collaboration over our shared
energy future if we fail wars over
scarce resources could be even worse in
the 21st century than in the 20th